to bring in Gary Klein the big news
yesterday was Jeff Fisher being fired
Gary thanks for joining us why now with
Jeff Fisher you know damn as you
mentioned I think this was something
that everyone thought might be in the
works here but the timing of this I
think coincides with this short week you
know you figured okay maybe they come
back from Seattle and that's the time to
do it because they have the open weekend
but I think given how they played it
against the Atlanta Falcons it was so
abysmal the Coliseum was emptying fans
were booing and the fact that they're
going to Seattle for a nationally
televised game where the storyline would
have been Jeff Fisher's chases the
losing his coach you know all the
controversies that have surrounded them
recently with Eric Dickerson in the
contract extensions I think they just
kind of wanted to put that behind them
and move forward and change the story
line if you will as they as they move
towards the last three games of the
season what role did the feud with Eric
Dickerson play in this you know Kevin
Demoff says this was a kind of results
only kind of decision but I think you
you've been in la enough to know what
it's like here and when that Dickerson a
situation came vehicle e exploded it
reminded me of you know Lane Kiffin
Steve Sarkisian all the kinds of things
that happened in LA with football the
last 22 years it really was an LA moment
and I think while they kind of said it
didn't have anything to do with it
there's no question a given Dickerson's
profile and just how public he was about
the situation and what was happening
that that had to figure on some level
into Stan Kroenke s decision to part
with Jeff Fisher it was four o'clock
eastern time yesterday and the number
one name trending not in sports the
number one name trending was Jim
Harbaugh in the possibility of going to
the Rams can we separate fact from
fiction here of what you think the
likely wish list candidates will be for
this job well I think our boys name uh
you know rightly so is is going to be up
there it's going to be discussed and
again this is the time of year where
every coach in the country uh worth his
salt is going to get his ray
is because he's gonna put his name or is
it floated it with a job like this but I
think the name yo Harbaugh I think out
here really the one that's trending the
most is Jon Gruden and I don't we
probably talked about him over the years
with some of the other charges opened
out here but I think this is a real
possibility being in LA uh a young
quarterback a defense a little you know
pretty much in place there are some
things that are going to be very
appealing about this job for a lot of
coaches and maybe this is the one you
know that get screwed and back into the
game well yeah he's been murdered i
think so well I i understand it I just
don't know if Gruden would be sold on
Jared Goff you know because Gruden works
out these quarterbacks and I don't know
what his opinion is a Jared golf
privately publicly seems to love
everybody but privately does he love
Jared Goff and where was this offensive
line this year and where was Todd Gurley
III is Jeff Fisher and his staff are
they that bad of you know offensive
minded people that they couldn't get
anything going that is one of the great
mysteries as you mentioned this is the
same offensive line essentially that
walk for him last season when he was the
offensive rookie of the year ran for
more than a thousand yards and 10
touchdowns in only 13 games so that is
one of the great mysteries you know when
you're talking about offense guys like
Josh McDaniels Kyle Shanahan those who
named those young coordinators names are
gonna come up as well um so according to
them off they are not going to limit who
they're going to be looking at whether
they have had NFL head coaching
experience or not but again I just think
because it's LA because they want to
continue to be in the new cycle with
positive types of things I don't think
they're going to be able to escape name
such as Gruden and as you mentioned Jim
Harbaugh Gary thank you good luck and
safe travels thanks very much down all
right Gary Klein covers the rims for the
LA Times the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]